to solve this what do we do now what I
want to remind you are is the fact that
I know we can think of three functions
and that kind of thing are not in terms
of angles and triangles we can think of
just never function though sometimes
helps if you think of it in terms of
angles because um sine inverse of that
the tenuous of that if both of those
angles then the whole thing is also
angle right so let's call that feed off
okay now the reason why that is helpful
is because it reminds you of the fact
that if what you're really trying to
solve is an angle then you can bring in
other trig functions to help you solve
being right so for instance I mean you
guys have been sick to death over the
last few days of taking the derivative
of both sides or taking the integral of
both sides well based on the functions
we've got why don't we just take the
sine of both sides so I'm going to have
sine theta on the left hand side right
and then what you get on the right hand
side is sign of now I know this is
monstrous right but it's just another
one of the questions you've already been
doing right so this is a this is B okay
so if I'm taking side the whole thing
this is sign a plus B okay which as you
know is sign a Cosby that's cause a side
be okay just the expansion that you use
the the earlier parts of the question
right now by the way you didn't have to
choose sign you could have chosen pan if
you want it or cause all you need is
just the expansion that breaks these
park okay and now you solve it just like
you solved the other ones so for
instance cited us of three or five okay
which I'm call me a that means it's in a
triangle triangle title okay and so I
can to do this right we're all right to
put in a triangle because site in verse
means you will restrict the domain
already okay it's only between this and
this so therefore I can stick it in this
their problems so a is here and I've got
side which is opposite over hypotenuse
or three onfire that makes that form
okay so there's the a triangle and 4b
this scale is going to be awful but you
get the idea
I've got ter which is opposite on
adjacent right so opposite honor Jason
which gives you that there's your high
pop so now put your leg okay sign up a
well and I already know what sign of it
is it's through cause of B is adjacent
by hypotenuse which is 24 hi okay cause
of a forbids sine of b 7 on 25 so if
you've done your numbers right you can
get sent to dominate up rights 125
that's 72 that's 28 so 100 so fit okay
now remember the reason why I too
excited both sides is similar to widely
different shape both sides or you
integrate both sides so that you can
work with it in some way you could
before but of course that means that's
not my control ads because this is not
the enough this is safe either okay now
four fifths is not some nice neat exact
value so unfortunately the most precise
that these ads against now let's see
because they didn't say approximate so
you have to leave it exactly that's it
okay the reason why this doesn't fly for
like earlier questions is because when
you're in this position you take side
about sides you can simplify okay so
this is as low as it gets so that's the
solution okay so